welcome to this video playing FM alka
alka from from Israel let's see no name
I wanted to play the bank oh I have or
maybe a been only car let's play abalone
for once and see what happens hmm okay
an on theoretical line Bishop c4 okay
frankly speaking the bishop does not
belong there at all but I guess he has
some some idea
okay so hmm yeah maybe get maybe you sir
use this for tempo um c4 can also go b5
here maybe because of Queen B 6 yeah
maybe benoni is relying on those kind of
its kind of tricks all the time you get
this somewhat strategically on dubious
position but you can very often justify
things by concrete tactics Knight to d7
95 queen bee six still with c4 c4 coming
and in the meantime he has weakened as
e4 square he cannot even take b5 because
he for hangs and then threatening before
how does he protect you for now
yeah I don't know isn't this quite good
for black already okay so at least here
I don't have air between b6 intending c4
check winning a piece okay PS Bishop c4
okay now all that that's not very much
not very frightening but still yes the
move Bishop a six then years a four okay
see form now that's not very good okay i
guess i should start with that
efore now on Bishop a 6 a-4 s is pretty
useless okay i'm doing i'm going to do
this yeah maybe Queen B 6 wasn't a good
idea I could have played this
immediately and then go with night b67
that that was better it was probably
better okay I mean that's not a bad
position for black button but still okay
so should I take here I guess I should
be should be five queen bee five
yeah I'm still behind on the clock ever
felt I wasn't so slow but I still was
yeah but it looks nice yeah i just won
this pawn and b2 is hanging and there's
some disharmony in in whites in whites
position if we consider yeah okay I can
take
yeah okay don't want to spend even more
time here this is probably okay for me
and more than one way and if I spend a
juicy m he will use this time advantage
yeah those loose pieces efore and III
maybe I could have done something about
this but okay spending even more time as
mentioned is probably not helping me
rupee ADA is a plan
can go night a 497 those kind of moves I
may be here come on tune in to see three
I don't really know what 96's is doing
now the pieces will lose anyway but this
feels like there's something wrong with
it I think
93 on some somewhat tech here against
this Queen a 30 so looking so almost
double the check is good this is will
loose material around 9423 will loose
material at the end let's see for 23 24
bishop a one root k 1 loop c8 until we
lose you lose something I don't I don't
think he can keep his stuff together now
yeah Queen fo takes on a one rook takes
rook c8 and if the Night Moves III drops
was check maybe he can play rook see one
then maybe okay so he's playing like
that but I have this move night again
hanks and ninety two friends yeah as
mentioned his pieces are loose and now
something's dropping
yeah this is sometimes an issue with
those aggressive setups like with F form
you have weakened lots of squares in
your camp III is the next problem
it was a weird setup anyway with Bishop
c4 I'm not really a benoni expert but
that this piece is wrong on c4 is pretty
clear nice getting the clock run down I
guess yeah
the poor man's way of resigning did I
plane before yeah two and a half points
out of three not bad yeah sometimes
understand when people are frustrated
that day is some more let the clock run
dongle I mean he like four things I do
was just I thought at least i outplayed
pretty convincingly um okay let's let's
have a look here I went with b5
interesting okay the computer wants to
take it does not like my sacrifice that
much okay I was thinking that this is
quite interesting like a get got its got
this move which I underestimated really
check something like that isn't totally
clear but it's also yeah it's murky
murky stuff okay went with this and no
I'm just better right yeah nitey to g4s
even stronger okay this this forum with
about equal player that might be true
but rather quickly i got i got d5 with
with a good game okay took here and this
was the the kind of simple simple
solution 96 seems to be okay even but is
this is good for black right i just have
the better coordination here and yeah
Queen c3 was good okay but this isn't
bad right yeah black is clearly better
after 23 as well that's that's good and
Knight c3 winning out it was some it was
a pretty typical case that when you push
your porn say like f 4 u.let cam good
outpost for your pieces yeah the bishop
for example is always loose the poor
will be back on f2
then it's not that bad actually about
the specific position would be bad as
well but yeah you simply have posts for
your pieces while here white has some
many weaknesses that I can use okay
thanks for watching